tout arrive trop tard les masques sont
arrivés trop tard le fait qu'on ne
dépiste pas les gens qu'on n'ait pas de
masque pour mettre à la population
[Musique]
l'exemple de la corée du sud je le cite
souvent mais ils ont réussi à enrayer
une épidémie qui partait vraiment très
très fort parce que la population est
masqué par ce qu'ils ont fait des tests
massif parce qu'ils ont suivi les
personnes qui étaient contaminés et
qu'ils ont réussi à les contrôler et
donc malheureusement on prend la leçon
de cette pandémie mais il est clair que
on peut pas se permettre de ne pas avoir
de stock pour protéger la population et
pour protéger le personnel soignant ou
sait très bien que quand ils ont dit
qu'un deux jours de confinement et qu'on
a vu lors de des français qui quitté
paris pour aller se réfugier en province
ils avaient tous compris que ça n'allait
pas durer 15 jours tous ceux qui
pouvaient partir et qu'il y avait du
télétravail sont partis avec armes et
bagages et enfants et ils savaient très
bien que ça allait durer ça allait durer
plus qu'un jour même si en faisant ça
ils prenaient le risque de faire flamber
l'épidémie il semble quand même que
c'est pas été le cas et que une fois sur
place ils ont été raisonnables on les a
contraints à être raisonnable le
gouvernement vous savez il a failli il a
fait ce qu'ils pouvaient un bon ils ont
constaté
ils ont constaté qu' il pouvait pas
avoir de masques que deux le stock de
masques avaient disparu ou n'avait pas
été renouvelé il avait quand même deux
mois pour leur faire et relancer la
machine à fabrication française puisque
en chine visiblement on se piquer les
les contenus des avions sur les tarmacs
parce qu'ils sont plus offrant donc tout
ça on
on est à la merci le on est à la merci
le président a rappelé enfin qu il
fallait qu on ait une indépendance de
production pour les matériels de
protection
il a pas parlé de l'indépendance de
production de test et pourtant c'est ce
qu'il faudrait avoir visiblement ce
gouvernement des pôles seuls en europe à
ne pas avoir réagi à un llodra il y aura
une morale il y aura une des consignes
et des conclusions à tirer de cette de
ces tristes épisodes et de cette
impréparation et j'espère qu'elles
seront vraiment tiré en ce moment parler
de déconfinement est totalement
prématuré 534 morts par jour 800 hier on
voit bien que ça ça ne baisse pas et je
pense qu'on fera sans doute le bilan à
la mi mai mais à la mi mai on sera
certainement pas tirés d'affaires il
suffit de regarder des italiens qui ont
15 jours d'avancé sur nous ils sont loin
d'être tiré d'affaires et on parle pas
des confinement donc il faut rester il
faut rester confiné maintenant il ya ya
que cette il ya que cette façon de
contenir l'épidémie de faire en sorte
que comme dans tous les autres pays il
faut éviter que les services de
réanimation soient débordés parce que
qu'on ne se retrouve pas dans la
situation italienne où ils ont été
obligés de choisir entre ce qu'ils
allaient réanimer ce qu'ils n'avaient
pas réanimer
pour le moment en france ça tient mais
ça tient à un fil et je pense qu'il est
prématuré de parler des confinement
[Musique]